uh so ep's coming
here nice sooner if you come Away album
Top of the Year album Top of the Year
already got features for the album yeah
how do you put which eggs in which
basket this is EP music this is album
music so the name of my EP oh because
it'll be out by time yeah not the EP
won't be out but by the time we drop
this interview the song will be out the
unless we put it out in 20 minutes yeah
not then it I if you I'm just kidding
we'll wait we'll wait I was gonna say if
you put the [ __ ] out of 20 minutes no no
no no you'll be like yo you're talking
to me your turn around incredible yeah
like nah you know I see editing over
there right now he's not all right but
no no so so so what's the name so the
name of the uh EP is Boys Don't Cry I
like that yeah so you know how you you
said like you know I'm the vulnerable
artist yeah man like you know as as men
we always start to be tough I mean and
not have emotions to do this do that
whatever the case may be um
it's just it's just you know leaning
into you know allowing allowing men to
be vulnerable and uh
and show that like you know I'm looked
at as the artist that make songs for the
women and [ __ ] like that which is cool
um but it's all right that's meant to be
vulnerable yeah it is man that's always
more songs for women there's more songs
for women it's just a whole tape for for
the [ __ ] yeah something like that not
really it's a couple songs for the dudes
but it's a it's just it's allowing
yourself to be vulnerable bro I mean
because at the end of the day bro
all that tough [ __ ] bro is for the birds
man
like it's like it's not who don't like
[ __ ] bro
this is true
I don't like [ __ ] like I mean I know a
few guys that don't shot little nazex
true yeah true yo my producer Cyrus